there's an article that's been floating
around on a website called everyday
feminism which the anti feminists and
the men's rights activists and the anti
social justice warriors hate and they
are absolutely going nuts about it and
the article claims to point out a
variety of tactics that Donald Trump
used during his first debate against
Hillary Clinton that are being
characterized as ways in which people
are sometimes emotionally abused in
relationships and I've looked at the
article and I I have to tell you the
article is very valid outside of the
feminism context a lot of people are
talking about this in the form of a
gender context Trump oppressing or
abusing the female Hillary Clinton and
it's on a website called everyday
feminism I want to ask you as someone if
you are someone who has sort of
anti-feminist tendencies let's evaluate
what the article says not in the context
of feminism or gender roles or men
abusing women or anything like that I
just want to analyze this from a merely
social engineering and manipulation
perspective and I believe that this is
actually a very good article and I think
it's a distraction to write it off
because of the website in which it
appears let's take a look at the list
now of the ways the ten ways in which
Donald Trump manipulated during that
first debate and again the website calls
it emotional abuse we can call it social
engineering manipulation whatever number
one lying okay
we covered this extensively Donald Trump
lied a lot during the first debate and
number two is denial denial is related
to lying often the denials are lies for
example denying that he ever said
climate change is a hoax created by
China
okay so denial and lying I think we'd
pretty much understand blame-shifting is
number three when Donald Trump was asked
about the many small businesses that he
didn't pay when he built his business
empire he actually shifted the blame to
business owners saying maybe they just
didn't do a good job so blame-shifting
another technique that Donald Trump used
number four moving goal posts Donald
Trump does this all the time he did it
several times during the debate Lester
Holt actually tried to sometimes remind
him what the question is that was
actually being discussed just changing
the topic of what it was he was
discussing and this is related to
manipulation technique number five which
is bait and switch it's similar to
moving the goalposts when Donald Trump
was pressed about releasing his tax
returns he said well listen I will
release my tax returns when Hillary
Clinton releases her 30,000 deleted
emails the audience somehow cheered for
that but that is a total bait and switch
there is no relation between the forty
year track record of candidates
releasing their tax returns and what is
going on with Hillary Clinton's emails
that are completely unrelated number six
general I'm sorry number six is
projecting rejecting is when the
manipulator accuses someone else of
doing that which they are being accused
of so Trump does this all the time
you'll remember when he had that
situation where he referred to megyn
kelly as someone who was bleeding out of
her you know where type of thing he was
very very aggressive and inappropriate
with megyn kelly
he later disgusted as saying megyn kelly
had been not nice to him I mean just
textbook instance of projection number
seven is generalizing and exaggerating
Trump does that all the time things are
a disaster they're tremendous he uses
the words everyone or always when he
actually should be saying a few people
and some of the time this is a common
one I think we understand that yelling
and shouting over somewhere between 30
and 50 interruptions of Hillary Clinton
during the debate I think we understand
that fear mongering everything terrible
will happen if Mexican immigrants come
to the US if Hillary Clinton is the
president whatever that one is easy to
understand and lastly is body shaming
he didn't directly body shame Hillary
Clinton or the moderator this particular
week I guess he didn't find anything
about Lester Holt appearance he wanted
to talk about but he did slip in this
comment about the 400-pound guy who
might have done the hacking and again I
don't understand how the weight of the
of the hypothetical hacker is at all
relevant here so this is a very good
list if your takeaway from this list Pat
is oh this is this is feminist nonsense
you're missing the point I think that
this is a very valid and worthwhile list
to take a look at I'm not sure if you
noticed this but when Trump is being
interrupted himself yes this tactic of
saying excuse me oh yeah yeah you did
that once and Hillary no longer
interrupted him for the rest of the
debate yeah it's a very good it's a
strong tactic I mean it works because
part of it also can be if you're just
the loudest person very often if you
imagine walking into rooms and I've been
in these rooms where there's one
particular person in a social situation
who is very clearly the loudest person
in the room even if you don't like or
respect or agree with what that person
is saying you will very often start to
acquiesce to the fact that they are sort
of in charge of who is talking and when
and how much time and have loudly and
the the counter of excuse me of Donald
Trump speaking over the interruption is
really effective and it worked during
the Republican debates and it certainly
worked against Hillary Clinton so listen
don't focus on the fact that the website
is everyday feminism you can remove this
article completely from any feminist or
gender ideals and it's a very very
interesting article to look at